- Hi, good afternoon, I'm
delighted to have many of you here
on Zoom for our fourth panel
on how to join the Quantum Workplace.
My name is Florian Carle
I'm the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute,
and I'll be the moderator
for that session today.
So we are delighted to continue the series
of professional development
panel that are organized jointly
with the Engineering Workforce Development
of the Center for Quantum
Networks in Arizona and YQI.
So this is the fourth and
penultimate panel in our series
and today we are focusing on
how to prepare for startups.
So there's many, many ways to
enter the Quantum Workforce
and build quantum technology.
And it requires a lot of
different backgrounds.
We need physicists, we
need electrical engineer,
we need computer scientists,
software engineer, chemist,
and so on.
And so it can be a bit overwhelming
for people to find the
right carrier for them.
And so today we want to share
this information with you all.
So in this series that has been recorded,
that you can go back and go
back and see on our website.
We talked about how to peak
your courses for college,
how to join grad school, how
to become a faculty member.
And then today we're doing
startups and in December
we'll do industry jobs.
So today we'll hear through
a few young professional,
what it's like to work in quantum,
how to land a job in a startup
and why not create your own.
And before I introduce our panelists,
I would like to give the space to Matheus
which is the student leadership
concealed chair of the
Center for Quantum Network.
And you will say a word about CQN.
- Hello everyone, thank
you for introduction.
Well, I'm really glad
to be the CQN president
representative here today, essentially CQN
is a Research Center funded by NSF.
That surprisingly has a goal
to build the quantum network.
And you can think that a quantum network
is the generalization
of classical internet,
the classical internet
for quantum computers.
And we conduct research in many fields
from the development of
quantum hardware and algorithms
to the investigating the associated impact
of quantum technology.
And in addition to research,
we also look at education
outreach and workforce development
as pillars of our center.
And part of our goal, it's
also develop activities
to foster academic and
professional development
in the student population.
And we'd like to learn more about,
CQN feel free to reach out to us.
You can look at our website
and also email me, thank you.
- Thank you very much and
we have some information
on the slide on my webcam.
So now let's start of the panel.
Let's introduce our panelists.
You can turn on your webcams
and then we're gonna start
by Iu-Wei Sze, about QCI.
If you want to talk a little bit more
about what you do over there and like,
why are you interested in
quantum physics, Iu-Wei Sze?
- Okay so, I'm a Iu-Wei Sze,
I'm a Software Developer
at QCI or just Quantum Circuits.
Our office is our New Haven
Science Park and about myself,
I came from computer science
at the University of Connecticut.
I have a bachelor's degree there.
I went into software consulting for a bit
before I went to database developer
for a healthcare company
and then finally QCI.
So about me, I guess I,
as a software developer,
I'm deeply integrated
in contributing mainly
to the software stack and about QCI.
It was founded in 2015 by
Robert Schoelkopf, Michel Devoret
and Luigi Frunzio and their colleagues.
So they're the leaders in
the quantum computing field
and if also professors at Yale.
We have a pretty big
multi-disciplinary team
of hardware and software engineers
to build the most advanced
quantum machines out there.
And our goal, our
mission mission is mainly
to deliver the world's first,
truly useful quantum computer.
That's it, I guess, feel free
to ask me any questions you have.
- Sounds good, thank you very much.
And it's an interesting
fun fact, is that your boss
is also my boss in a different etiquette,
but that was interesting to see.
Let's go to a second panelists.
Mehdi, do you want to introduce yourself?
And I put up the slide about QA.
- Awesome, awesome, hi everyone.
I am Mehdi Namazi, I'm the Co-Founder
and currently the Chief
Science Officer at Qunnect.
So Qunnect is very, very similar mission
as what Matheus was saying.
We are trying to develop the hardware
and the software necessary
to upgrade the current
telecom infrastructure
in order to make it much
more quantum friendly.
So not only for applications
like secure quantum encryption
and such, but also to eventually
connect quantum computers,
quantum sensors, and
pretty much any device
that has quantum nature into this network.
So we just want to be the building blocks
of what will come much later,
but more towards the
concept of quantum internet
and network designed to be plot for any
and to be used for any quantum device.
I am from a physics background.
I did my PhD at Stony Brook university.
I was a postdoc fellow at YQI
for what was it more or less
18 or some months or so.
- Yeah.
- Yeah and then around two years ago,
I left and full-time joined Qunnect
currently we are at at Brooklyn Navy Yard.
A team of 10 full-time
scientists and engineers
mainly focused on developing the hardware
that can be used for these applications.
- Thank you very much and
then let's have Victor
introduce themselves
and I'll pull up the slide for Tsai CITY.
- Thank you so much, Florian.
And so my name is Victor Padilla Taylor
and my pronouns are he, him?
I was born in Nicaragua and
actually immigrated to Guatemala
because there was a civil
war in my country of origin.
There was actually someone
that loved engineering.
So got my bachelor's degree
in chemical engineering.
And then everything started
just rolling towards
administrative roles and
corporate development.
Eventually I moved to the
U.S to get a master's degree
with a Yale School of Management
and then moved to non-profits
with the World Economic Forum
and spent four years
until someone invited me
to come here at Yale
and support the creation
of these new center for innovation,
the Tsai Center for
Innovative Thinking at Yale.
So my role as Director
of Networks is to create,
a space for innovators,
like you all to find support
for their startups, nonprofits,
or even create a project.
So I'm really happy to
be here and hopefully
I'll be able to provide some
resources to all of you.
With us here, Tsai CITY there's a way
for you to work on your ideas to fruition.
- Thank you very much.
So let's start by like
a question that I had
when I was planning this thing.
It was like the only thing
I've never worked in a startup.
And the only thing I have in mind
is the very Californian vibe of like,
ooh, everybody's working on a scooter,
they have free cafeteria.
That's my vision of startups,
which I know it's, that's entirely true.
Can you take a crack at what
it's like to work at a startup
and what differentiate a startup
look a more formal company
and what's your day-to-day
like, who wants to start?
You can just unmute and go.
- I can go first.
Yeah so yeah, there are
plenty of the startups,
like the Silicon Valley of Styles.
We are a little bit different, more lanes,
no noise scooters for us.
But I think the biggest
things that differentiates
between the startups and
industry jobs, that I'm sure
you guys will cover in a month or so
is the combination of the
flexibilities you get.
Like, we don't have any time
who comes in, what time,
who lives in time?
No one cares about these things.
No one cares about how
many days you take off
or like what you do.
All we care about are the
general milestones that we have
and the things you want to achieve.
And the startup is usually a
much more collaborative space.
It's not like an industry that
the mission is already built,
defined, and usually
everything is designed
to optimize the revenue.
For example, whatever the businesses.
In our case and in most startups,
you're still figuring out
what the mission is even gonna be.
So every player, everyone
who joins the company
is less of an employee
more often by all means
and purposes of teammate,
because everyone needs to work together
and everyone needs to have
several hats to the final goal.
So it's a little bit less boring
when it gets to the job
roles that you have.
You get to pick, you can
switch for a lot of projects.
Anytime you start a new, or
if you have a better idea
for how to do the projects,
any case like developing
the Quantum stuff,
if you have a better idea of
people are there to listen.
Things are not set in stone,
but of course it always comes
with this bigger risk
that it is a startup.
You always wondering, like
what happens in a year,
in two years when he
gets to like the fundings
and everything like that.
So it has its own plus and minuses.
- Sure, I guess I'm next.
So I think a lot of it was covered already
to add to that a startup
coming from industry
or big corporations,
there is more structure.
So for example, what this
means is in a big corporation,
when there's a feature we often go through
and have a whole like session
where you discussed this
with like the managers, the business side,
they will approve this feature.
And then finally, when it gets to you,
it's definitely gonna
be that it won't change.
There's no, like...
There's always a very clear
like map of everything
that you need on by the end of this week
or this iteration or the sprint.
Start-ups is a little bit more free
in the sense that we try to keep up...
We try to keep like a structure as well
for iterations, for example.
But due to the fact that we work closely
with like the hardware
engineers who use our software,
we at the same time are also
production support for them.
'Cause it's not like we
have a separate team for it.
And when features come in,
they sometimes get prioritize in one way.
But as we're going
through this might change
due to various reasons.
Could be because people
want one thing sooner,
it could be because we just
like wanted to switch it
'cause it wasn't as because some feature,
wasn't as important as this other one.
So the structure behind a
startup, it's a little more free.
This is good or bad, it depends.
You get used to the flow over time,
but coming in, you might
be a little overwhelmed,
like, wait, we were supposed to deliver
this for this upcoming iteration,
but now it's like taken out entirely.
Don't think about it until next iteration.
- Yes Victor.
- Yeah, can I have just a warning.
- Yeah.
- I do agree, with our colleagues here,
when will you compare
the work of a startup
to the work inside a corporation?
The work in a corporation
seems kind of mundane.
It can be boring even it's
exciting to work with startups.
And as as they were saying,
different hats, adapting to change.
My only warning is that oftentimes,
all these, innovation and exciting,
I would say behavior within startups
can be easily just be innovation theater.
And you gave the appearance
that everything is,
working towards the goal, et cetera,
but you're just, not
necessarily progressing
towards actual change.
And so that's my only warning,
sometimes founders will come your way
and they will promise heaven to you,
and you can actually decide
to follow their footsteps,
but you will go down instead of up.
So be careful I'm not buying
just innovation theater
and make sure that you're
really buying into a vision
that has a lot of execution involved.
It's my only warning, I
think innovation can be found
in multiple spaces within corporations
as well with startups.
- So to jump on that,
what are the key signs
that somebody who's looking to join,
like looking for a job in a startup
should look into not like,
I feel that you warning us
about not drinking the
Kool-Aid of the founder
that has all the solution,
and then being like,
oh, we're gonna we're to change the world
with our company.
What are the key aspects that
somebody should look into?
Like when you're doing
your research for the job?
Go ahead.
- So, yeah, this is pretty interesting.
When I looked for QCI,
I asked a lot of questions
about the success
of quantum computing and especially why
the architecture they chose
for example, is superior,
or has a greater chance of success,
or even a chance of success
compared to say Google,
IBM or any of the bigger companies.
So not to promote QCI too much,
but most of the ideas from Google and IBM
were actually taken originally from Yale
behind the Yale research.
So a lot of batch was
like one of the movie...
One of the reasons that I
felt there was that finale
going to be like, there...
It wasn't gonna fall on space basically.
And I researched them
into quantum computing
and where it goes.
And there's definitely
a lot of hype around it.
But the main thing is there's
also progression in research
as we get closer to completing
this quantum computer,
it's not like stagnant.
So this is like a good sign that something
can definitely come out of it as well.
Yeah, I would definitely
ask a lot of questions.
I actually asked the
person who interviewed me
a lot of stuff, like, so
why does super conducting,
for example, this method
for superconducting cubits?
Why does this feed out like trap ions
and just get a feel of like, how you...
I mean, basically just get
a feel of like the company
and how it's looking and they
know where they're going.
It's definitely a fine.
- Mehdi.
- I totally agree with these things.
I just wanna add few things yeah.
So one of them is that
unless it's like a startup
that is just starting
and you'd like to literally
one of the first employees
definitely have in-depth
conversation with people
who work there already, not just founders.
So definitely find someone
if you're in physics,
definitely find their physicist, engineers
and see what they think about the company
and the startup rather than
the founders, of course,
founders are there because
they really believe in this.
And that doesn't necessarily
like give you the information you need.
But looking at the people
who started this startup,
I mean, these are all
quantum we're talking about.
Yeah, a lot of people in this field,
whether it's a startup or even researchers
have the issue of tunnel vision everyone
like thinks that what they work on
is kinda like not everyone.
Of course, some people think
that what they're working on
is gonna change the world.
It's very important to understand
that we are all parts of
like a small ingredient
of this bigger revolution
that we want to happen
and not a single company or a startup
it's gonna be that big
game changer to create like
the next generation of technologies
that's gonna get widely adopted.
So it's very important to work with people
who understand this level of risk.
They understand that this is
a very, very earliest stage.
I don't wanna even call it industry,
quantum is not an industry.
There is no revenue, there is no market.
There is nothing.
You're talking be more
working to are something
that could have a lot of potentials,
but possibly could not.
Someone like we worked with
a lot of room temperature
vapor technologies at Qunnect for example,
who knows maybe in some five years,
someone come up with
something much, much better.
And that's the technology
that gets adopted
or like entirely like
different ways of communicating
or computing using quantum properties.
So it's very important to work with people
who have this understanding that how risky
and earliest stage these things are
and how open they should be
always to pivot and change.
- And Matheus you have your hand raised.
Do you want to add
something that question?
- Yeah, I guess I have a common,
it's really nice to
hear about all of this,
and I guess it is important to feel
a little bit about the innovation
and when you hear someone talking to
or really excited about something
they want to kinda like
give you the impression
that everything's gonna be great.
But I also think that
you should fear that,
but also you need that.
I guess startups need that, right?
I mean, they need this drive to go beyond,
and believe that they're gone...
They will eventually change the world.
And maybe not by themselves,
many startups can change the
world doing the same thing,
I believe there's a space for
a lot of different companies,
but I guess it's yeah,
you should be careful,
but I guess you should also
feel the hype at some point,
and I have a question, actually,
I worked in a startup before,
and I'd like to know your perspective
on how important it is,
to exchange knowledge
when you're working on our startup.
Because when I was an intern
at our startup, it was amazing.
I would talk to everyone,
we would know everything
that was going on in our company.
And I think it makes you grow so much
because you were already...
You're always in touch with people
that are doing amazing things.
So what is your perspective on that?
- Who wants to take that question?
- Okay, I can jump yeah,
no, it's everything, exchanging knowledge.
And like, especially
having this understanding
of how bigger things come together
is super, super important,
in both sides it's very important.
So one of the things we
did at the beginning,
when we wanted to hire, for example,
and have the senior
scientist in the teams,
we picked senior scientists
based on two things,
only people who are smarter than us
and also and better in physics,
but also the ones who
worked on different fields.
Yeah so not that far off,
but the ones that have
different experiences than us,
because we didn't want to
have the same exact experience
and background getting together.
So everyone can have a more
base to solve the problems
and move things forward.
But right now we really
try to push for this
now that we are a little bit
larger with like 10 people
who not all physicists like a lot of them
like either directly came from undergrad
after their physics or
electrical engineering
and positions like that.
We do a lot of these
conversations about like
still this side of like journal clubs
and like progress report
on each of the separate,
like six projects that we have.
But for everyone, because first of all,
we really want our team to grow
because everyone who works for,
we want them to eventually
get better jobs in the future,
if they leave us or anything
that happens with the company.
So we want them, for this to be a place
for them to learn more also.
But also a lot of times,
like we are developing
so many things that eventually
need to come together
and work together.
So it's very important for us that
if you have someone, for
example, we have an AI scientist,
we're focus on one position right now,
or one project right now,
what's important for us
that she knows everything
else that goes on very well,
because even making much
easier for her to know that,
okay, she can adopt the same mechanisms
and helping this side, they can...
How everything can come together.
So we do that very often.
We have spent several hours per week
making sure everyone is on the same page.
- You wanted to add something?
You can unmute yourself
and feel free to or unmute yourself.
- Okay, yeah, I interpreted
the question the other way,
if you mean like how much
we know about, for example,
what the hardware engineers
are doing versus the software.
There is always like a weekly
meeting where we will sit down
and actually have everyone go
over their general progress.
And like, if there is any
questions or anything,
this could be taken to another meeting.
Sometimes the easiest
way is also just talking
directly to your coworkers
because a startup we're really small.
And there's like, I mean,
we're all basically like
go to lunch together, for example.
So it's easy to ask a question
and just like catch up
or anything that doesn't make sense.
Or if you're interested
in the bigger picture
of what this feature will do,
there's often a pretty simple,
like walk up to your
colleague kinda thing.
And that's like a good
way to get basically...
And we have weekly meetings as well
with just like the hardware
and software engineers,
just to like smaller
groups to go over exactly
what is going on and how
the changes in hardware
might contribute to changing
the software, et cetera.
- Yeah and I'll say that, I
think at the end of the day,
we're talking about
behaviors, so transparency
leads to clarity and with clarity,
you can actually collaborate,
which was something that Mehdi
said earlier in the session.
I remember, right after,
our graduation ceremony
at Yale seven years ago when I was here,
I was going through sort of
some offers that I had to work.
And I actually got an offer
from the Silicon Valley Company
where one former classmate told me
that there was no such
thing as transparency.
All of these teams were working in silos
and team A wouldn't know
what team B was doing,
and that was on purpose.
And I just think that there's a barrier
when you create this sort
of culture to collaboration.
And so, I would actually, consider culture
as one, as these warning signs
that you really need to pay attention
before committing yourself
your talent to a space
where yes, it could be nice,
nice windows and the scooters
and anything you like, but
this base doesn't make,
I would say the culture
and I think that's one key,
I would say a check box
that you need to mark,
a good culture for innovation
for your professional career.
- Great, it's interesting
you're saying that in your fancy
new building with windows
and fencing couches.
(laughing)
- I'm home, Florian.
No, all fancy but empty, so equally dead.
- We have a question in the chat for Mehdi
being in a leadership role,
how much technical and
scientific work do you do
during the day-to-day?
Both when you studied
at you Qunnect and now
versus the management of
people in the company.
Like what's a day-to-day look like,
are you hands-on science or
your more management now?
- And I wish I used to be
very hands-on on science
at the beginning, which is like,
usually the reason you start a startup
because you want to have
basically your own research group
outside the academia and quantum startups
are pretty much all like research labs.
It's just that the findings are different.
And the people you pick are different
and more diverse technical
backgrounds, especially.
So that was the original dream.
But as we grow, a lot of
responsibilities keeps coming in.
Some of them are a little bit annoying.
For example, like we have
several that are grants
from several different agencies
and many different
investors, and you constantly
have to raise money constantly.
You close around you happy for whatever
the hour after you're pitching
again, like one hour later.
And even though like, I do
that a lot to still stay
like hands-on on the experiments.
I used to be the CEO for
the first year and a half
of putting things up.
But then I found someone who
was much, much better than me.
And I put her as the CEO
currently for the past two years
to be more focused on the science.
It's very harder for us to do hands
for me to do hands on and stuff,
because I feel there
are two things usually
that takes most of my day.
First of all, I need to be all this, like,
make sure all the
projects are going forward
and the way they need to do so.
Pretty much I have to be
talking with everyone everyday
to make sure they have no problem.
Everything was going forward.
If you have any questions, any issues,
but also fact that I feel like
I mean it's this like continuous
two years learning curve,
because everyday someone
comes up with a better idea,
like, hey, let's build a
quantum memory this way,
hey, let's this use this technology
or entanglement sources or
products or something that,
and then I have to go
learn quite a lot about,
I think if I didn't know
in much, much more depth
to see if it makes sense for us
to start budget for it.
Where do we bring the money?
Who do we need to hire
and stuff like this.
So I haven't done hands
off stuff, honestly,
in the past six months or so fairly too.
We still do a lot of science,
but very soon you pretty much
become this PI who's whose job
is to just make sure
everything is moving forward.
And the bigger picture is happening.
- All right, great.
And speaking of money,
there's always these stress.
When we think about startups
that's oh, we don't know
if we're gonna have the
stability of your jobs here,
but quantum is currently in a space
where there's a ton of
money getting poured in
by government agencies, by
companies, by exponent investors.
Is it something, can
you share a little bit
with that entering like
a privileged information
in your startups?
Can you share that the funding like
I do you feel stressed for cash
or is it something that's the
stress of not having a job
in a year or two years?
Like the, is something elevated
by the fact that the us
government has these quantum hubs
that are created like a lot
of fundings for all the...
I know it's hard you still
have to do request grants
and RICO's funding, but
like, what is the landscape
in the funding of startup in quantum?
I know it's a tough question,
nobody wants to answer.
(laughing)
All right, go buy it man,
- Sorry guys, I don't
wanna talk to them much
but there's something we
deal with all the time.
Yeah so I don't think
for anyone net startup,
especially like whether you're working
or founders or anything,
no one is really worried
about their future jobs,
because it's so easy to get
hired if you work in a startups.
A lot of people, both in the
industry and everywhere else,
they know like how versatile you get to be
if you work in a startup and
how many things you learn.
So that part is good and
usually our goals are not
officially as founder.
My goals are not what happens next month,
or do we have money for this
part or something like that.
Those are very easy.
The problem is the bigger picture.
Yeah, because now you're
responsible for 10 people,
then it turns to 20 people
and something like that.
And although we have like, it's a startup,
you always have a lifetime.
Yeah, so like, if you
have budget for one year,
that's like, you're very, very fortunate
when it gets to the
startup world on average.
Like if you're secure for one year,
but if you wanna make sure things happens
after that year, now is the time to worry
about where does that money comes from.
So start up is pretty much a cycle of,
hey, do this pre-seed and
seed and series A, B, C, D,
and then there's some
things in the middle,
like you can breach and stuff like this.
There's like infinite number of like names
because how often you need to raise money.
And that it gets much easier over time.
Like for us, like every
time we had to raise money
and bring money, the first
batch was the hardest one.
Like we had this seed
round that was very modest.
At the very first time
we wanted to raise money.
It was 800K, it took me eight months
to raise the first 100K
and like a month and a
half for the other 700.
Like when you keep bringing
money and you have success,
everyone wants to be
affiliated with success.
With it's much easier, even
with the federal grants
and stuff like this are the first,
it took us like a year and
a year easily with 100K
in federal grants and
then the next 18 months
with 4 million.
Things change very fast
and then you go under people's radar.
But yeah, so that's
always the general picture
of funding the issue,
especially with quantum,
because quantum is awesome.
All these things are very promising,
but the problem is that in order
to attract private funding,
a lot of people had to do a lot of hyping
that is not necessary in
long-term sustainable,
because you need to
encourage a lot of investors,
why they should come put
money in a technology
that may not even have a dollar in revenue
in the next 10 years or so for you.
So the problem is that a lot of companies
have this insane amount of evaluations.
Like it's very like unmatched
market size right now.
And it could go in a past
that after a few years,
investors become much more strict about
where they invest in their money,
how much they're putting
on what conditions
and what evaluations they're
bidding to put their money
hasn't happened yet.
I've been warned about this
quantum winter pretty much
since I started the startup
route and hasn't been here yet.
But there's always a
possible reality of happened
with the AI happened with a
lot biotech companies, FinTech,
all of these coats with the
cycles that people lose hope,
and they're not willing
to put that much money.
- Thank you, I have a
question for you, Victor,
regarding the resources
that student can can gain.
So we have a ton of people
in the chat and coming here,
who are students in college
and might consider joining startup?
Is there a activities,
or is there a project
or experience that they can
get to sort of have a taste
on what it's like to do startups?
So we have people from
Yale, but also from Arizona.
So if you have resources from Tsai CITY,
but also if of general,
a more general advice
for that will be very helpful.
- Yeah, thank you for
the question Florian.
So yes, before you actually
go to the marketplace
and see yourself
interviewing for startups,
you can actually try these
worlds out with Tsai CITY.
There are multiple ways in
which students can get engaged
with Tsai CITY.
I would highly recommend to take
a leadership position with Tsai CITY.
What that means is that
everything that we deliver
in terms of training, in terms
of, working with startups,
we do it through student employees.
And so you could actually check out,
at the beginning of each semester,
around 40 to 45 opportunities
for employment at Tsai CITY,
that will give you a different flavors
of what it looks like to be in
based innovation ecosystems.
You could be a product specialist
delivering a marketing
proposal for one hour startups.
You could be a portfolio manager,
actually managing not one startup,
but supporting maybe three
of them in our accelerators,
because, that's one of our main programs.
You could also support some
of the training sessions
that we deliver for the founders,
student founders that come to Tsai CITY
in legal matters, in operations.
We also teach students how to hire people.
And so again, one way
was you can get engaged
with Tsai CITY, is just
become one of our leaders,
student leaders working alongside with us.
Now, if you wanna be on the other side,
which is the receiving side
Tsai CITY has two levels
of incubation for ideas.
The most basic level
is called an incubator
that is main Launchpad,
where you can come and
get support and training
on how to think through
some of your own ideas
and give them shape.
But then we have another
level of incubation,
which is called accelerator,
where you get funding,
you get mentorship, you
get also more training
and you can actually,
feel what it looks like
to be out there talking to investors
and doing your own fundraising around.
All of that is kinda skill development,
We think that once you're
out there in the marketplace,
we'll give you quite a lot of experience
on how to deal with the
real things out there.
You will have certainly better questions
to ask your employers for future employers
regarding the starter that you
may be considering joining.
So again, come work with us or
just come and ideate with us.
We have multiple entry
levels, the incubator lever
or the accelerator level that
would of course provide spaces
for students in the audience.
- Thank you very much and this applicable
to all the universities, because
Tsai CITY is a Yale entity,
but I'm pretty sure that
every university in the U.S
and pretty much in the world
have these kind of innovation hubs,
that I'm sure you can
find a leadership position
in your thing.
We have a question in the chats,
how would you compare working on a startup
to compared to working in a
university, like toward a PhD,
towards like a research thesis.
And I'll add to that question,
like, do we need a PhD to enter a startup?
And so that's a question for you guys,
like, what's the difference?
What was the biggest chunks
and what was the similar differences
between these two worlds?
Iu-Wei Sze, you want to answer this?
- Sure, I was looking for
the hand raise actually.
So I actually don't have a PhD.
I just have a bachelor's
in computer science.
'Cause I went...
Well, I can't speak for the physics route,
'cause I'm not sure about that.
But for software developing
a lot of what you do,
a lot of what you apply
in, like any environment
is very similar.
The software paradigms, software design,
all this like work that you usually get
from like a computer science in general
is very applicable to not
only quantum computing,
but also other fields in general.
So in that case, I don't
have a PhD, but here I am.
As for working like the
startup compared to,
I would say startup is really much,
I worked at a research lab before.
It's pretty similar in the sense that
you are really close to your colleagues,
you definitely work alongside on them.
You know like what they
want you to deliver.
And you go through and talk
about your progress every week.
So I definitely got a very similar feel
to working at a research lab
compared to working at a startup.
And it's good because you
like being close to people,
you know a lot more about them
and they don't feel like they're just
someone who sits across from you.
- Thank you, Mehdi do
you have a word on that?
- Sure, yeah, yeah, no, no.
It's definitely not just for PhDs.
Honestly, my experience is
that I say this very bluntly.
If you want to join a quantum startup,
if you want to know one of
the indicators to know like
how much the people in
charge know what's going on
and planning properly,
if you see a startup that
is like 30 people plus
not the very earliest stage
ones in terms of employees.
If you see more than five, six PhDs,
that's probably not
the best place to work.
Yeah, it's pretty much
just a big research lab.
I know startups and companies
that have more than 50 PhDs in physics.
I have no idea what you could do with 50.
You can have like a whole university,
like it's like crazy number of PhDs.
So like the started with
of course with more PhDs,
because the very beginning
you need more PhDs,
but over time you need less and less.
So right now we are like
half and half, five and five,
but we are now planning to
expand to closer to 30 people.
And like only two of them are gonna be PhD
from the next 20.
Now that you're hiring,
like we will get to a point
that engineering software,
all of these matters significantly.
And even in the business side,
these things matter a lot.
So if you're keep hiring PhDs,
especially from like the same parent lab
or the founders came from,
it's never gonna change
from like a research
Institute beyond anything.
It's always gonna be just research.
- Matheus Guedes De
Andrade since you started,
you were working in a university
and you also work at a startups.
Do you have any input on that question?
I think we have.
- Yeah, so my experience that
it is similar in some way,
I think that startups are
like research companies.
And then yeah, the feeling that you have
of going to the lab every
day, it's pretty much
similar to the filling you have
to go to the office every day
in a startup, I guess I would say.
I also, I think that the main difference
is that on the startup,
you know your goal roughly,
and why are doing research,
a lot of things can happen.
A lot of things change, but
I guess that's also true
for startup work.
But I think that when you are in a lab,
you will often see people
changing what they're studying,
changing their thesis
directions and all that.
But I think it's really,
really similar, I would say.
- All right thank you and
so we have two questions
in the chat that I think
we can merge into one
because they want to
know what's more valuable
in you hire in a startups.
And so the question has
two components sort of like
are people looking for
more hands-on scientists,
for example, somebody
working in physic techniques
on an AMO, or like what
kind of transferable skills,
a PhD, or like your hands-on research
and science do would be
valuable for a startup?
Like what kind of, if
you're hiring people,
what kind of people are looking for?
Then I know there's also
different stages of startups.
And so what would be the...
There was a way to do it.
Yeah, go ahead and unmute yourself.
- Okay yeah, so what do we look at most?
Yeah, so the, I mean, of
course it really depends on
the continent startup
you're talking about,
like, there are startups
that are like solely software focused,
like for the error corrections,
quantum algorithms,
even I know, like in
quantum communication size
there is like algebra computing...
Sorry, aliero quantum in MITSP not,
which is like purely on the software side
or for quantum communication.
Obviously this place is
really, really prefer.
Obviously they prefer like
people with the background
in the software's full stack
developers, especially.
For us, everything we do is
light matter interaction.
So AMO backgrounds are better,
but what we cared the most
about is not the backgrounds,
or how much hands-on
experience people have,
but more like how willing people they are
to constantly adapt and
constantly do new things
and learn and grow with the team.
Because most of those things,
a lot of the things you're doing here,
you can learn in like six months,
we started with one of my team members.
He was just a lab tech, when
he started within nine months,
he became one of the product owners
for one of the things we're developing.
There is a lot of room to grow.
It's all the matter of like,
if you're the type of person
who really wants to grow
in a more accelerated pace
than for example, like a six year PhD.
- So you're talking about growth.
Okay, I have a question for all of you
when you're looking
for a job in a startup,
or why would you stumble upon a startup
and then got that job?
Like, were you aiming
for that kind of career?
Or is it something that's fell onto you
and be like, oh, that's
a good opportunity,
I'm gonna take it.
Yeah, yeah good, great.
Just unmute yourself
and then start talking.
- All right so I did come from
two industry guys beforehand.
I wasn't looking for in
particular, a startup
as much as growth in
general for healthcare,
like being a database developer,
there's only so much room you can grow
like on the front end,
if you're just doing
backend work, for example.
So I just wanted something
that would give me more growth
towards a software architecture,
which is more of what
I want to do or maybe
that's definitely different
from a lot of people here.
But yeah, so I think in
terms of how I landed here,
I was mostly talking to my recruiter
who was out there looking for people.
He said, some professors at
Yale has this company going,
and they're doing some
quantum computing work.
They're looking for software developers.
If you're interested, I could
get you in touch with them.
And I just really enjoy,
like I came to QCI
for the interview.
I liked the people, they were really nice.
And we had like good discussions
about quantum computing in general,
that I wanted to get more
involved in this field.
And that's how I got here today.
- Mehdi.
- Okay, yeah, I was always
a big fan of startups.
Yeah industry wasn't the thing for me
just happened to be
like a lot of my friends
who went to Intel and stuff like this,
they were really not
happy, especially after PhD
because their jobs
became like very boring
for them, very fast.
And that academia wasn't also
superior holistic for me,
the academic paths of becoming a PI,
because like, it's a very,
very competitive space.
And I always work in places
where people around me
are very much, much better than me.
So I was like, even if
there's openings these people,
these are a bit more than me,
like at Yale or anywhere yeah.
But and also with academics
is a little bit tricky.
Especially if you are an experimentalists,
there are a lot of
universities and positions,
but not that many universities
that you get this decent chance
of being able to get grants
and stuff like this.
These things are still, depending
on like your success rate
always depends on like
which university you're at
and stuff like this.
Startup was a good route
because it will give you a
lot of these flexibilities
that you immediately get for
free as like a PI pretty much.
So it was like a loophole to jump on
and suddenly become the PI of your group.
Like if any one of you is in New York,
you're always welcome
to come visit our place.
It pretty much looks like a research lab.
Yeah, we have plenty of optical
tables, so many experiments.
We do everything from
tabletop experiments,
all the way to, and
also even like theories
and simulations.
All the way to actually building a product
that can be bought and be used
like in a more plug and play format.
So we have a lot of research
and it was a lot into it.
And it was like a little bit
for me, less stressful more fun
to be able to put a team
of all different technical
backgrounds together
engineers, physicists,
software developers, AI people
towards something that I was
just really very passionate.
- Thank you, we have a very
loaded question in the chat.
And so I'm gonna read the question now
and then talk a little bit about it.
Is it better to train a quantum
physicist in engineering
or to train an engineer in quantum physics
for quantum startups?
And so it's interesting
because that question
is literally the reason
why we hosting these panels
because there's gonna be a
shortage in Quantum Workforce.
And so basically there's a ton
of startups getting created.
There's a ton of research
lab, new labs, new hubs,
new industries are building in quantum
and the limiting factor
is not gonna be funding.
It's gonna be the finding the people
who are qualified to do that.
And it's really not
fair to ask for somebody
who just got their PhD in quantum physics
after six to seven years to start
for quantum computer
science engineering degree.
And the same way we cannot ask
somebody who just got there,
the degree in engineering
to go for a full PhD.
And so the reason why
we're doing these things,
because we can really
have the super people
that have like hands-on on engineering
and then also on contraceptives
and know how to build this thing
and know how to call things.
So the idea is to try
to find spots for them
and have the qualified
workforce in different spot,
the same way that some people
who will work on software,
we'll talk and work closely with people
working on the hardware,
but we'll have very different skillsets.
And so I think the idea of like
having these super trained people
is not really doable and realistic.
And so the it's most likely
you should pick a phase
like a subject that you like the most,
because at the end of the
day, you're gonna do that
for like the rest of
your life, more or less.
So it's something that
you need to figure out
something that you want to
do or that you enjoy doing,
and then pick that branch
and then follow that.
And I think no matter
where we're one lens,
if it's like in theoretical
physics, it's an engineering,
it's in software, it's
chemistry for the application,
it's in material science.
There's gonna be a lot of
applications on the roads
to work in quantum and so.
And there's also a whole branch
that Mehdi was talking about
of non like physicists
you're gonna need people
able to financing,
getting some accounting.
Some people getting capable of pitching.
And so there's a ton of thing
even if you're not working in quantum,
you can still like on the
quantum topic themselves,
you can still join some quantum startups.
And so that's something that's,
you have to keep in mind.
- Florian if if I can
pitch Tsai CITY for that,
we can teach students precisely
those additional skills.
We can teach students to fundraise,
to create a very compelling pitch deck,
to talk legal contracts.
At the end of the day, it's a business.
And if you have a
business, you need lawyers.
And so how do you can...
How can you talk the same language
that you need for business?
We can also teach you marketing skills.
We can teach you how
to work collaboratively
with your team.
And so there are a lot of soft skills,
non-technical skills that
of course are required
for these growing space
that needs more than just quantum doctors.
- Yes, that's true and one
thing that could be very,
a valuable tool is all around
the world online and on-sites,
there's some are quantum hackathon.
So it's this competition that lasts.
I think they're less usually in-person
over the course of a weekend,
but the online version
span usually the time of a week
where you can work in a small team
and a solve a problem.
And I think this is closer
to like a mini startup
that you can do, you find a problem
and then you want to solve it.
And so you bring some of
the team members together
to really try to solve that.
And so I think that
that's something closer
to start startup that you
can get to give you a taste
of if it's something that you might enjoy
and the kind of work you want to do.
So look online, I know that IBM
has a ton quantum hackathon
using their IBM Clouds.
We wake YQI and Tsai
CITY hosted one last year
with all the students at Yale and at...
I forgot the other
university, sorry about that.
If Victor, if you remember the university
that was hosting with us, oh, Berkeley.
And then, so that's something
that could be valuable to you.
So we getting close to the
end time, I think to finish,
I would like to give
you all the opportunity
to add your end command and note of like,
should we all jump into the startup world,
quit our day job and then join a startup?
Or should we just be more mature about it?
And if you have any jokes,
opening that you want to
pitch for your startups,
that's the what to do.
If you have anything,
like, please take that time
to do so, who wants to start?
- I just wanna touch on
something that we didn't discuss
that that much, but
like in the continuation
of what Victor was saying,
if you're thinking about
starting a startup.
So if you're from physics
engineering background,
you have a good idea, you had a research,
you've worked on something,
and now you want to
start founding your idea.
Please go find someone
like Victor from day zero.
And it's spend the time
to learn all those skills.
Yeah, it's totally normal.
But you realize this very soon,
you hear this all the time
that founders like us,
people like me who came
from like pure background,
technical background,
make a lot of mistakes
that stays with them
for the rest of their, like
the life of their startup.
And you always think that that's not me.
I have a PhD in physics,
I can handle this.
I can understand business stuff like this.
Believe me, you make so many mistakes
that forever haunts you.
It's like so annoying and forever like you
sit in front of the investors
and you're like, yep, I was very dumb.
Yeah, that was me three years ago.
I did that, I gave that
equity to this person.
I did like this, I took this money
that I was not supposed
to, things like that.
So there's a lot to learn.
So like really when you think
about starting a startup
plan for like literally a year,
at least six months of learning,
what it takes to run a startup,
raise money and stuff like this.
And each university
has someone like Victor
that is more than happy to
help you grow in this past.
- Thank you, Iu-Wei Sze, word of the end?
- Wait, I didn't raise my hand.
But sure, I can start
off, I was just gonna say
for startups definitely do your research
and know about like what
you're getting into.
It's not that scary,
I mean, it's more like
if you want to work in a certain field
and you just so happen that
they have your interests
definitely go for like,
why not go for a job
that you would like doing
than just some random thing,
like working in corporation
that you just like sit there
and get pigeonholed all day?
If that's what you like,
that is what you like.
But yeah, I mean, definitely
working in whatever field
that you feel has a
lot of interest to you.
And so you will get passionate
and do a very good job
and you'll learn a lot more too.
'Cause your interest also kind of links
to like more knowledge.
As for the question on, like,
I can't speak too much
for the hardware side
because I don't work in hardware,
but I know we aren't
looking just for PhDs.
We're looking for people we can also teach
that have like a physics
degree or something...
Like something, a mechanical engineer,
actually electrical engineer,
all kinds of different degrees.
So these are also people we
can teach in lab as well.
How to do like a certain
process that we're using,
this stuff is teachable.
Having a background is definitely good,
'cause then we can start off from there.
And yeah, it's just
putting that out there.
We are hiring both software and hardware.
There are various
positions on the website.
Feel free to check it out.
Software I mean, you might
see me during the interview.
All we ask of you is like,
you have computer science knowledge
and have a very solid software
engineering background?
And we don't ask you to know
quantum physics or anything.
- Thanks and then you can
see on the top right corner
of the QCI website, you have a karyotype
and I think I've seen in
every startup website,
there's a fine Jonas carrier.
There's like multiple
tablets, it's blinking.
It's really the time to get a job.
All right a few words for
the end matches you have a...
Do you have a word to end,
like a last final comment?
- Oh yeah, good luck on
your job search for sure.
Definitely look at what you want to do,
where you start off in your
career is that where you end it?
So if you feel like you
wanna get into something,
definitely do it while
you still have time.
And I mean, honestly, you're
still young unless you're not,
but most cases, I mean, most
of the people I'm talking to,
definitely you're still young.
There's definitely a
chance to change your path
and get into it before.
Yes, that's it, I don't
really have anything too.
- Victor, do you have a final comment?
- Yeah, so, it's just
building on what Mehdi said.
Start a world is full of mistakes
and learning to deal with these mistakes
or you can call them failure
is it's quite important
for entrepreneurs and innovators.
At Tsai CITY we have a
safe space for you to try,
learn and try again.
I think it's one of the things
that we are very proud here at Tsai CITY.
Because we know that this is a skill
that will stick with our students
for the rest of their lives.
- Perfect, I would like to thank you all.
Oh, Matheus, do you have a final word?
Sorry there.
- Oh yeah I guess
I do have a final word.
So, one thing that a
professor of mine told me
this past month is that
research is all about failure
and how you deal with it.
And I think that's really
close to how an entrepreneur
needs to think about things.
You need to be okay with
failing and it's fine.
And I guess it's really
about not giving up
and then pursuing your dreams I would say.
And I know this is for startups,
but if you'd like to apply for a PhD
or pursue a master's degree,
Sukiyan has a lot of physicians,
a lot of professors
working on a lot of things
you can work with quantum algorithms,
quantum hardware and all that.
And feel free, if you are interested
and feel free to check our website again.
- Perfect, I would like
to thank you all of you
for your time and for your
insights on the startup world.
It has been a very
fascinating conversation.
Thank you so much for your time.
And I hope everybody in the audience
pretty enjoy the conversation.
Thank you all and we'll
see you on December 10th.
If you're interested in learning
about jobs in the industry.
Thank you all have a good night
and good luck for your squid game, Mehdi.
- Thank you guys, have a good night.